should Scotland be an independent
country that's the question the people
of Scotland face on September 18th
I'm Dina and here's what you need to
know about the Scottish independence
referendum Scotland is deciding whether
or not to become an independent country
so what well a united kingdom without
Scotland is a big deal but first if you
need a quick refresher on what the UK is
that's okay the UK is basically a
country of countries England Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland Parliament is
based in London and the Queen is the
head of state so why would the Scots
want to break away from a union that's
lasted for more than 300 years the
pro-independence campaign yes Scotland
believes they will be richer if they
break away there's still oil left in the
North Sea and Industry to develop its
organizers say small countries look
after their people better and provide
more affordable social services who
disagrees better together the No
campaign that includes all the biggest
political parties in the UK they argue
that Scotland already has the best of
both worlds the security of being part
of one of the biggest economies in the
world and limited independence through
the Scottish Parliament in Edinburgh so
what happens if Scots do vote yes a lot
of questions are still up in the air
will Scotland keep the pound can they
afford their own army will Scotland
carry out its threat to get rid of the
nuclear weapons on its territory what
would that mean for the military
alliance between the UK and the United
States and will an independent Scotland
be able to join in the EU European
countries are worried that breakaway
movements in places like Corsica
Catalonia and the Basque Country might
be encouraged by Scotland's example it
might just be up to the 16 and 17
year-old first-time voters to decide if
they're going to live under the Union
Jack or the Scottish Saltire
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook